on the first turn it can move either one  square forward or two squares forward  let us imagine that white opens the game  with the move e to e for this pawn on e4  attacks two squares to the sides either  the square on f5 or the square on d5 if  black were to place any of his pawns or  army on those two squares the white pawn  would have the opportunity of capturing  let's imagine that black responds in  kind with the movie 7e v the pawn on e5  now attacks two of white squares let's  imagine that white now moves his pawn  from c2 to c3 taking advantage of the  role that he can move upon either one  square forward or to an in-kind black  responds the same light now plays the  move d2 to d4 the pawn on d4 attacks the  pawn on e5 and in turn on on e5 attacks  the pawn on d4 let's imagine that black  captures the pawn on d4  and white recaptures  you